in the latest example of Ron DeSantis
showing he's simply not ready for prime
time and certainly not in a position to
actually win a Republican primary which
he may very well enter there are now
rumors that he will announce in the next
week or so Ron DeSantis was asked
yesterday did Trump lose in 2020 can you
just say like Trump lost there wasn't
all this fraud that Donald Trump talked
about and DeSantis weasels out and
refuses to actually answer the question
instead talking about how there's a
culture of losing in the Republican
party and blah blah blah blah this is
not a strategy that is going to win him
the primary I will explain why after we
look at the clip listen to this standing
for absolutely nothing that should be
Ron desantis's campaign motto
a culture of losing do you acknowledge
that Trump lost and there wasn't all
this raw that he talked about
well I look at the last however many
election Cycles 2018 we lost the house
we lost the Senate 2020 Biden becomes
president or no excuse me we lost the
senate in 2020 Biden becomes president
and has done a huge amount of damage
very unpopular in 2022 and we are
supposed to have this big red wave and
other than like Florida and Iowa I
didn't see a red wave across this
country and so I think the party has
developed a culture of losing I think
that there's not accountability and I
think in Florida we really showed what
it takes to not just win the question
was did Trump lose
these people are these are not serious
people win big and then deliver big and
ultimately when you're doing all this uh
what results are you producing for
people that's really what matters uh you
can sit there and talk about cable news
social media all these other things
that's not what the reporter was talking
about the reporter just said Trump lose
things that that people are fixated on
and for me it's like okay what's that
true north uh you obviously got to win
otherwise you don't get a ticket to the
dance and did Trump win you're not
answering the question sir once you do
that how are you going to be able to
actually bring about big change to make
people's lives better next yeah next
yeah this is not going to cut it my
friends this this is wishy-washy weak
nonsense
DeSantis is probably afraid of
alienating the loyal Trump base and the
loyal Trump base still seems to believe
the obvious lie the obvious lie that
Trump lost I'm sorry the obvious lie
that Trump won in 2020 they are unable
to accept the reality that their guy
simply didn't win and so DeSantis is
calculating well I can't just say yeah
Trump lost and he should accept it
because I might need some of those
supporters but the problem is that when
you're asked did Trump lose and you rant
for 80 Seconds about the midterms and
who the hell knows what else you
alienate
every American who's sick and tired of
the Trump lie that he actually won in
2020 which is of course
almost every Democrat the vast majority
of Independents and many Republicans as
well although certainly not all so
DeSantis wants to have it both ways here
he wants to be seen as a great
alternative to Trump to the Loyalists
and in order to do that you have to sort
of appeal to Trump's hardcore fans but
he also wants to be seen as the
pragmatic leader who can win over
moderates and independents and is
willing to just talk in a sensible way
but he seems completely unable to do
both you can't be an alternative to
Trump
if you can't just acknowledge what
happened in 2020 you can't be the leader
of the future if you can't say
definitively and clearly the 2020 thing
is over Trump lost Biden won period so
DeSantis I think is going to need to
make a choice if he wants to actually
have a shot at this thing which may he
may already not have you either stand up
to Trump and say listen
we share some values we disagree on
others but we need to ensure that
there's a future for the Republican
party we don't have that future if we
keep Dilly dallying about just saying
what needs to be said we were beaten by
Biden in 2020 right that that's one no
ambiguity no evasion we need Clarity
honesty I will never lie to you and the
truth is Trump lost that's one approach
it probably infuriates a bunch of the
Loyalists and therefore there is no
chance that they will even consider
coming over to to DeSantis the other
aspect to this is maybe what DeSantis is
trying to do
is just avoid the issue of 2020. like it
could be calculated it's it's it's not
about well I don't want to offend the
Trump loyalists or whatever but he's
just saying I'm going to play dumb and
ignore the issue altogether the problem
with that is you're not going to appeal
to enough Republicans who want a fresh
start and a new Direction you're not
gonna win back the people that
Republicans lost with all of this lie BS
if you don't very clearly Inspire
confidence by saying I'm willing to
Simply tell the truth and so it's really
a problem for DeSantis and of course the
bigger problem for DeSantis is a
mathematical one which is no matter
which of these approaches he takes
the average polling right now is roughly
Trump 53 DeSantis 23 plus or minus a
couple points and as I've said before
simple math if Trump already has more
than 50 of the Republican primary vote
DeSantis can't win even with every
non-trump vote it would only get him to
47 percent DeSantis somehow needs to get
some Trump voters to switch to him and I
don't think this approach is going to
help him he may be popular in Florida
he's not ready for prime time he's not
ready to take on Biden but never mind
that he's not even ready to take on
Trump so we'll see if we get an
announcement from him uh latest rumors
are anywhere in the next seven to 14
days one to two weeks we may be hearing
that announcement from uh Rob Des
sanctimonious as he was most recently
called by Trump on Truth Central when
you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your
activity private internet access
protects you from the price crying eyes
of hackers your internet service
provider tech companies private internet
access is also super fast for streaming
and for downloads you can watch your
favorite streaming platforms as if
you're in another country like the UK to
access cool new content and with just
one account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience 83 percent
off that's 203 a month plus four months
free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link
is down below